le temps de la pause déjeuner le préau
du collège s'est transformé en scènes
pour jeunes talents
[Musique]
héloïse amélie et claudia sont en 4e
elle s'entraîne depuis plusieurs jours
pour danser devant leurs camarades
si le lieu est original le public lui
peut se révéler intimidant y en a il
c'est super qu'ils applaudissent tout ça
il rigole dans tout ça mais après y en a
aussi qui critiquent et ça après mes
temps ça s'est très bien passé donc
depuis six ans le collège anatole france
participe à la semaine de la
persévérance à l'école dans les yvelines
un temps fort pour mettre en avant les
compétences inconnu et caché des élèves
et favoriser leur réussite scolaire et
ça permet pas aux enseignants et aux
élèves de voir les élèves autrement
quand un élève qu en échec quand il nous
montre ce qu'il est capable de faire
nous aussi on a un autre regard sur ce
qu'il est capable de faire et de le
valoriser
ça peut être des points d'appui pour
justement va l'aider mais dans sa
scolarité
ce midi là pendant une demi heure les
prestations s'enchaînent de la danse et
du chant devant des camarades qui sont
conquis et julien dans le rôle de
l'animateur en 4e et qui vont aux
comptes y voit à quel point on
s'appelait aux élèves salaire assuré
à la fin on peut s'acheter application
qui peut y avoir 10
j'ai réussi c'était très bien et ils
repartent en cours avec un grand sourire
et c'est ça qui est bien un grand
sourire pour reprendre les cours et pour
certains l'envi peut être de faire quand
ils seront grands carrière sur scène
[Musique]